une répression politique de plus en plus
forte
mais aussi des opposants de plus en plus
déterminés à quelques mois de la
présidentielle qui doit se tenir le 7
novembre le président daniel ortega qui
craint de ne pas être élu une quatrième
fois sur exploite la loi guillotine voté
en décembre 2020 cette dernière vise à
punir toute tentative d'ingérence
étrangère lors nous les nicaraguayens
sommes les seuls à pouvoir avoir notre
mot à dire et a décidé de la marche de
notre pays
il n'est pas possible que des pays ou
des états tiers des organisations
internationales qui ne sont pas
nicaraguayenne imposent leurs décisions
à un pays libre souverain et
démocratique comme l'état du nicaragua
un simple versement de fonds venus de
l'étranger dont bénéficie un grand
nombre de fondations et d'organisations
non gouvernementales peut justifier une
arrestation et un emprisonnement en une
semaine à quatre candidats à la
présidentielle accusé d'actes contre la
souveraineté et de tentative d'ingérence
étrangère ont été arrêtés ce mercredi
les partis d'opposition ont fait front
commun pour dénoncer les méthodes du
gouvernement
le régime ne peut pas se soustraire 6
millions de nicaraguayens désireux de
liberté ce n'est pas le projet d'une
seule personne
ne parlons pas ici de candidature le
régime a déjà démontré que même par le
biais un processus électoral truqué
il n'est pas prêt à se soumettre à la
volonté du peuple ce sont des actions
qui accentue l'insécurité juridique et
matériels que vivent tous les
nicaraguayens dans un pays que le
gouvernement a l'intention de
transformer en une vaste prison
nous ne nous excluons pas du scénario
électoral sachant pertinemment que nous
sommes tous exposés
c'est ce que je voulais dire en
conclusion nous allons continuer avec
celui qui reste
les etats unis qui entretiennent depuis
des années des relations conflictuelles
avec le nicaragua ont imposé des
sanctions financières à la propre fille
de daniel ortega et à des hauts
responsables proches du chef d'état
leurs éventuels avoirs aux etats-unis
sont gelés et l'accès au système
financier américain ne leur est
désormais plus autorisés comme le
démontrent ces sanctions il y a un prix
à payer pour les complices de la
répression les états unis continueront
d'utiliser des outils économiques et
diplomatiques contre les membres du
régime engagé dans cette vague de
répression
washington qui depuis 2018 ne cache pas
sa volonté de faire tomber daniel ortega
a récemment qualifié le président de
dictateur et appellent la communauté
internationale à en faire de même